[Bang] [Cheerful whoop]
[Laughs]
Hi I'm Andre Meadows and welcome to Crash Course Games!
Over the next twenty weeks, we're going to have some fun.
I mean Crash Course is *always* fun but this
time we're gonna have fun talking about games.
Now of course we're gonna talk about video games:
your Ataris, your Nintendos, your Sega Genesiseses, your Play Stations, your XBOXs.
But not just video games - also hand held games
mobile games, tabletop games, board games,
card games, sports games, virtual reality games
Even games going as far back as Ancient Egypt and China games you might not have ever heard of before,
but mechanics in those games that're still prevalent in games today!
That's a lot of games! But before we get in all these games, allow me to introduce myself.
My name is Andre! Ever since I was a little kid I was into computer and video games.
I used to have a Nintendo Entertainment system - of course - before that I had an Atari 2600.
And before that, I had a Texas Instrument TI994A.
Nerd cred!
And today I have my own Youtube channel
Black Nerd Comedy where I talk about all kinds of
retro, nostalgia, pop and geek culture goodness like TV shows, movies, cartoons and of course: video games.
Now video games might be a leisure activity but unlike what your parents told you
when you were a kid, or today, as a kid — or adult —
they are NOT a waste of time!
You know, video games that we play, they have a lot to tell us about the experiences of being human.
As a matter of fact, humans have been playing games pretty much as long as there have been humans.
And I can tell you, the stakes have changed a little since ancient times:
I mean, I hate coming in last in Mario Kart as much as the next guy,
But in Ancient Egypt, if you were bad at games
You could end up in Ancient Egyptian Hell...
which is kinda like Rainbow Road.
So in this series we're gonna play some games, we're gonna talk some history, maybe some science,
even look into gaming's future, and above all we're gonna have some fun
learning about this universal human behavior:
People playing games.
[8-bit Ending Jingle]